what's up everyone welcome back to the
collider interview Studio at Sund Dan
2024 brought to you by the fine folks at
filo filo is a groundbreaking company
that puts the power to Green Light
movies in the hands of fans and creators
if you want to learn more about filmo
check out their website
film. now I have the pleasure of
introducing the team behind Penelope
huge
congratulations I need to apologize in
advance I'm filling in for my colleague
usually I'm a big nerd and I do my
homework but this is going to be the
first interview that I Wing in a very
long time but I am a big admirer of
everyone's work so I'm very happy to be
sitting here with you and
congratulations on the show thank you
thank you all right so Mark a big broad
question for you to start here because I
love how you Champion independent film
making what is something that you have
always done since the very beginning to
support Indie storytelling and can you
also tell me something new you started
to do to kind of readjust to how the
industry has reshaped itself yeah well
what I always did from the beginning
which was uh focus on myself selfishly
and how to get my art out there because
that's usually how it begins um but then
you start to realize if you have a
platform and you have something to do
you should probably uh stop maybe
reaching up and begging people to bring
you up to their level and maybe look one
level behind you of people who are
trying to come to where you are and grab
their hand and and take them up and I
didn't figure that out for a little
while um but it is something you know
Mel's been running our company for a
long time and it's something that's
become really important to us um and not
just in that way that's like well we're
so successful we got to give back now
because that's part of it but I think
the the the fun part of it is that by
doing that um you know we get to get
rejuvenated by all kinds of stories that
we wouldn't necessarily tell so when we
Finance or produce someone's work who's
coming up we're getting their life
perspectives we're getting their
knowledge of a certain area that like
I'm like honestly just not in touch with
at all and we get to collaborate with
them and make something completely new
and so that's more what we're focused on
lately so I was reading a little bit of
about how this project came to be I
believe you came up with the initial
concept why Loop Mel in the way you did
what is it about her creative
sensibilities that you thought would
enhance the core idea that you came up
with yeah that's a good question um well
I started writing this show during the
pandemic you know and we had that lovely
quiet pensive time and I kept thinking
God it's so wonderful to have this space
my life is so busy and noisy and crowded
um and this is a show about uh a
16-year-old girl who abcon to the woods
to escape the trappings of her Modern
Life she doesn't say anything to anybody
and she doesn't even really know why
she's going she's she's just trying to
connect to something that she feels she
has lost um so Penelope is definitely
the 16-year-old female Avatar of me
that's really what I want to do um and
um when I started writing it I knew that
these were themes that were very close
to Mel's heart um and at the same time
Mel has been running our company for so
many years and has has really you know
for lack of a better phrase has taken a
backseat uh in terms of guiding these
creative projects being our producer
being the sort of like Den mother of
them all but has never taken the wheel
as a director um and so we started
talking about this is this could be a
really great place for her to sort of
take this material that I started off
write it together and then pass it to
her to really take home as a director
all right Mel I'm going to follow up on
that with you now when you jump into a
new role in that respect what do you
assume is going to be the greatest
Challenge and then how do you go about
tackling that challenge so that you
could then direct this uh show with
authority I mean I think um it was more
written than I'm used to when I direct
and so I think finding a way for Mark
and I to collaborate in that way of
finding a way for me to kind of imprint
my own self on there and figure out how
to tell it together um was a really cool
new experience for this project but I
mean I've been producing for 15 plus
years and um and you do a lot of
directing Without Really directing
you're the the ghost director on a lot
of those and um so I had many years to
just learn how to do it you know all
right can you take us through the
casting process a little now because I I
believe that I read there was a bit of
an extensive search for your title
character yeah our our casting director
Amy Renee you know really worked close
with Mark and I and we did a pretty wide
search um and I think it was like 400
girls and then I got a 100 pass to me
and uh and just kept boiling it down but
I think the minute I saw Megan um I we
knew we knew it was and I had you know I
had heard about Megan you know a year or
two ago from a close friend Lyn Shelton
who had directed Megan in her first
project little fires everywhere and was
like there's you got to keep your eye on
this girl so when Megan's little video
popped up I was like oh there she is
Megan I'll let you talk about your
experience in a minute but Austin I'm
going to throw this question to you
having worked with her as a scene
partner what is something about working
with her as the main character number
one on the call sheet of a show like
this that you are excited for more
actors to get to experience when they
work with her as a lead in the future um
yeah I mean she's very good she's very
free um has just a great light to her
you know which is really special you
know just to like have that inside of
you um yeah she's great scene partner a
respon I don't know it's was fun it's
just fun you know just got to kind of
like be there and kind of forget about
anything and just you know be with her
yeah always a good quality to have all
right Megan for you now when you get the
role what is the quality of penelopes
that you were most looking forward to
playing but then as you started to dig
into the character can you pinpoint a
quality you found along the way that
wound up being more creatively
fulfilling to incorporate than you ever
could have imagined originally when I
had first read penelopy and I read the
script I was very inspired because it
was something that I was used to the
sort of like outdoor Wilderness type of
girl getting to like explore nature and
getting to forage and do sort of new
things and at first it was kind of
something that I felt at home with which
is why I was drawn so much when Mel and
I started talking with Mark um but then
once I started getting into it I figured
out that she was just as lost as
everybody else and I think that was
really important to me because I
obviously am only 20 but at points in my
life I felt a little lost in what I was
doing and being able to explore that
with Penelope in a different sense and
finding myself a little bit more through
Penelope and that experience was very
enjoyable and kind of life-changing in a
sense I feel like this question is not
going to have an easy answer but I find
it fascinating because I feel like in in
most cases when a a story like this
comes up like the character makes the
decision to to do something like go out
into the Wilderness with such Authority
what is it like playing a character
confidently when the decision doesn't
have confidence behind it if you know
but I guess it's it might be more of an
internal feeling that can't be
articulated I think it's liberating I
think it's liberating to have a
character who knows so much of what she
wants to be in life and although she
might not know who she is in the moment
being able to feel those things and be
able to do them confidently and be able
to explore parts of herself that she
never really knew before it was
liberating I mean there's not many other
words that reflect how I felt in the
moment for that so liing was probably
the best thing that I have to describe
it I'll take it I'll take it it makes
sense so I I believe Mark you brought
this up the the idea of you know
disconnecting going out into the
Wilderness is uh very appealing to some
for each of you now just for fun what is
a skill that you would actually have out
in the wilderness that would serve you
well so you could survive but then also
what's like a seemingly silly thing that
you know you would never be able to do
and would kind of do you in if you went
out there like that I think something
probably that I would find important is
talking to yourself because if you're
alone that's very I was thinking like
build a fire but that's probably
actually the more valuable skill to have
keep yourself entertained I think is
something that is very useful um
probably something stupid is I don't I'm
not entirely sure to be maybe knowing
how to do a build a tent I mean it seems
relatively
easy sometimes it can be a little bit
difficult I always think like running
out a contact solution or like not
having enough toothpaste or something
which stressed me out that I don't think
I could survive without contact solution
I wouldn't be able to see it'd be very
disappointing I'm glad I'm in good
company um anyone else have some
examples a skill you actually have and
then something seemingly silly that
would do you in out in the wilderness I
mean I uh before production I took a
bunch of survival courses so I I feel
like I'm cheating a little when I say I
know how to build a Hut out in the
wilderness to live in out of leaves and
sticks um you were taught but that's not
a given that you're going to be able to
do it on your own to I it no that's what
I'm saying you did it yeah no dude I did
it I didn't see pictures you know what's
I I've always thought I had the best uh
sense of direction and then in one of
the classes they were like walk out into
the woods uh 20200 steps and turn around
and find your way back an hour later a
search party it's like where is Mel we
got to find Mel uh so that didn't work
yeah I can pretty much lay my head down
and sleep anywhere so that's like my
superpower is like is being able to
sleep in the woods like I'm really into
backpacking and and going out you know
and like to like 12,000 ft and sleeping
up there and like it can be tricky so
like that's the thing that I can do that
uh that is a little bit of my superpower
where I get taken down is like so
pooping in the woods all right let's
just let's just get it out in the open
here guys like um there was a time in my
life where it was fine to just bring
some regular toilet paper you know and
then you pack it out with you because
you want to be a good citizen but
there's this new thing now that these
little rolls and you pour a little dab
of water and it turns into like a wet
wipe and so now I've been spoiled with
the wet wipes and if I don't have my wet
wipe when I'm out there I turn into a
raving lunatic and and I need to no I
need to be like medevaced out without my
wet wipes it's just not sustainable I
can't believe I didn't think about that
and I went for contact solution and
toothpaste like there's a there's a
proper priority order that I missed
there Austin what you got for us oh I uh
I I want to expand my my knowledge but
right now I would just I would probably
pass away pretty
quickly um but I I don't want to be like
that uh forever and I I do like you know
I eventually want to spend a lot of time
out in nature it's been a lot of uh in
my car sleeping in my car um but yeah I
I'd like to figure out all the other
stuff you roll down the windows one
night a little bit and then you can like
open the door and just like slowly get
yourself a little bit out imersion put
some yeah let my sleep with my we could
work on that right now Mel what's a
what's a tip or trick you learned while
uh while doing that course that uh could
be a good like starter step for someone
uh oh man the one that I always loved
was that you take cotton balls and you
dip them in Vaseline and then you always
have like a fire starter that's kept
waterproof safe that's a little tidbit
that's pretty dope yeah that's pretty
dope that a very good idea um so I have
to incorporate our filo question which I
absolutely love because again the
company is all about putting creative
control in the hands of the creators and
I think this industry needs a lot more
of that so whether it's on this project
or something earlier in your careers can
you pinpoint a time when you didn't
expect to get creative control but
someone believed in you and they gave it
to you and a project turned out better
off for it I mean there's
a yeah I'd say there's a related story
with with Penelope um because this was
something like when Mel and I finished
the writing of these scripts you know we
were at a place where we were like okay
this is is like the most important thing
that we have ever made and we need to
get out here we need to do this right
and we started sharing those scripts
with companies who traditionally Finance
them and we realized that they weren't
really prepared to make a slow paced
show about uh a young adult girl's
growth towards nature and and in the
time of euphoria that's just not what
they were ready to do and if we were
going to make it with them we were going
to have to make some pretty significant
changes in order to do it um so you know
we're no strangers to self- financing
films and bringing them to Sundance
we've done that for years but an 8
episode television series is a whole
other ordeal so it was not so much a
case that Mel and I were tapped by
someone who believed in US Mel and I
kind of looked at each other and we like
we believe are we doing this are
we doing this yeah let's go and took
essentially the biggest financial and
creative risk uh that our company has
taken so far
no no big deal no big deal at all we're
not
nervous no we I like I keep saying it
all day here like this is the
manifestation table you're going to get
everything you need the response you
need at this festival and it will soar I
can't wait to see it who has a who else
has an answer to the I think you're
brilliant I think you're right
yeah I'm I'm GNA clip that out and apply
it to everything I do um who else has an
example of a time when they got creative
control when they didn't expect to get
it I
think I don't want to sound redundant
but Penelope I mean I was given so much
creative like freedom and how I was
responding to the things that I was
talking to myself so I was able to
respond to myself and the nature around
me and being able to do that and having
Mel there to like help me push to
something greater was I don't think I've
ever experienced something like that she
was very helpful and just kind of let me
roam free and who Penelope was and kind
of figuring it out as I went and I
couldn't have asked for something more
creative and amazing it was you invented
the Penelope Dance I mean you it
happened out there in the woods what is
the Penelope dance well you're going to
have to watch the show can I get a te
nope no I'm sorry that's I mean that's
very effective uh marketing it's working
on me I actually have an answer related
again back to this yeah you have to talk
about Penelope no but it it is it's
actually the first thing that came to my
mind but there's this um song that I do
in this and I you know I I play and I've
you know written you know some things
for fun and stuff like that but I I
can't remember where it was kind of I
dawned on me that I was going to have to
uh somewhat create this thing like
myself like they did like Mark sent me
like some lyrics and stuff like that but
then musically like I needed to create
everything and then like there was like
changing of like the lyrics and stuff
like that but that was a great like
trust in that because I thought they
were maybe just going to send me
something to to play or something like
that um so that was yeah that was cool
to have that kind of confidence I
remember when you sent that demo back to
us I saw and I was just like this is so
played on repeat all day it was so
perfect independent television is a
little rarer than independent
filmmaking what piece of advice would
you give to someone who wants to make a
show independently and they're afraid
that it's
impossible well well how much time do
you
have um first of all uh that advice will
come you know in a in a a couple of
months once we know how things go for us
um it's a little fresh um but I do think
that um you know what we're staring down
right now in the industry is not as
similar to what happened in the 90s and
the early 2000s that really helped
create a healthy environment for
independent film which was they stopped
financing these special stories because
they were scared they weren't going to
make money so we had to find a new way
of doing it and that's where independent
film Emer emerged and we're watching
these lovely streamer companies that
created the birth of really incredible
television um start to die out now um
they're having problems so there's going
to be a dir of really interesting unique
storytelling in TV and so now's the time
for us to start thinking about doubling
down on that or it's just going to
die anything you want to add Mel before
we close out no I think that's it I mean
Mark and I say it all the time but it's
just like find a way to make something I
like that pep talk right there um
congratulations on Penelope I really I
can't wait to see it it is a feat to
make a show this way so congratulations
you all deserve it thank you for sharing
your experience with us today thank you
being here to everybody out there stay
tuned more from Sundance 2024 for you
very
soon